Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters and this is an overview video on what you'll be experiencing in the next coming weeks
Well, we're going over what we're fighting and what we call our complete initial
workup and testing
So why do we do this?
Remember what I am all about and it have always been about what God has put up my heart is to get to root causes
It doesn't make any sense to try to
solely treat your disease whether it's cancer or anything else
By just treating the effects of what has happened in your body
We want to get to those root causes
So you have to ask that question why why do I have that and how many times have we heard from cancer patients that they've asked that question of their own
And got to know where or or blank stairs or where we don't know or whatever
We know when genetics first came up we thought that we'd find genetics to be the cause of all cancers
But that is not the case now there's genetic factors
That's why we want to run people's genetic profile
Because there's detoxification factors and histamine factors and all sorts of different factors
Defects and tumor suppressor genes and things that can lead to the continued growth
But remember what causes a cancer is something got inside of a cell
And damaged the nucleus sending it into rapid replication that is by definition what cancer is
What is that something is it a toxin is it a biotoxin?
You know what is what is it that that got in there and did that damage
Well, we want to find out the why we want to deal with that
while we're
Quote
Treating the cancer carried for the patient helping them get rid of what's going on
We have to get rid of what caused it as well or we're not going to really end up being in a better condition
So we're going to do a number of different things
Part of our initial workup is we got to get to figure out that cause and get to a protocol of care
You're going to get a cheek swab kit in the mail
You're going to cheek swab your mouth put it back in the bag send it back to us through the cheek swab
We're going to come up with your initial primary protocol
What is going to be specifically for your cancer what I think through the testing
I think it's going to be the best protocol for you
We don't watch out on 50 different things
You can't take all that stuff that it's going to it's going to overwhelm your liver and detox pathways. It's
You just can't do that
We have to be on a more specific type protocol where you're on
Less things that are going to be more specific and better
You know to you and we have to do cheek swab tests in the future because your protocol can change
And your protocol will change a little bit and tweet be tweaked when we get your labs back or you're genetics back
So but we start with the cheek swab test to find out what diet is going to be best for you
And what specific nutritional protocols going to be best for you
And then you're going to get some lab kits also
They're going to be blood test kits. They're going to be urine kits
They're going to be hair analysis kits
They're going to be stool sample kits
Depending on what we want
To to dig into for your case everybody's
Case is a little bit different partly based upon that
That initial case review that you had with me and partly based upon
Your diagnosis and the labs that you've already had we got a dig into find out
Cause in all this all this testing we're digging into figure this out to know what the best protocol for you
With the slant understanding of cancer. I know a lot of you have been to other functional medicine doctors
Had it been put on things that I don't I don't like I don't recommend because
That's not what you would do for somebody who has cancer
We don't want to cause the cancer cells to stay alive. We don't want to
Slow tumor suppressor gene. So even in the case review
I may have said stop this stop this stop this that you're taking when you gave me your list of supplements because
You know, you have to have that understanding of cancer
What you're doing the testing what you're doing the recommended. So
We want to get labs done some of the labs are going to be specifically for toxicities because that's probably the most common thing
That gets inside of a cell and damages the nucleus
So a lot of our tests are going to be based upon toxicity panels
um
Do you have specific toxins that you were exposed to?
Unknowingly most the time and that you bought your body just didn't get rid of them
When you don't get rid of something it becomes a part of you and it can stay in the extracellular spaces
And it can be pushed intracellularly and when it gets inside of the cell
it can damage
different
Components of that cell if it damages in the nucleus and causes it to go into replication
That's what cancer is
So we want to discover what toxins that you currently have in your body and then help you pull those out specifically
Then we should be able to do another retest and see changes in that
That's what our goal is for you our labs may include different hormone testing
So testing for different hormones because some cancers are hormotally driven and we want to make sure that those hormones stay at a healthy
um space so that it isn't
Blocking apoptotic pathways of your cancer cells
And then some of you will be doing genetic testing
So we're going to look at specific genetic pathways that are
Influencing detoxification that are influencing
Uh cell replication because they're blocking
Um tumor suppressor genes or they're stimulating tumor oncogenes
So we want to look at all those pathways in a
In that
Light of cancer and then through all of this you'll receive what we call our protocol binder your playbook
It's going to be a three ring binder that says it's going to have the details of you could eat this but stay away from this
You're going to be on this protocol take these supplements this time of day take this drink here
Whatever that binder protocol is for you and that is a living instrument
It's not going to be that way for the next 10 years
You may be on more things now and you may be on less things later
You might be on less things now we may add things later partly depending upon when the testing starts coming back
Do we need to tweak things?
So once you get that binder and you start following that protocol
You're going to also be talking to me
Those are different reviews. We're going to be going over different lab reviews
Well, your toxicity testing gets back. We're going to set up a call where we're going to talk through those
And I may say hey, this didn't come up with the cheek swab
So we need to add this supplement to help pull this out this toxin out or it also came up with the cheek swab
So we don't have to add anything else. I already have you on that or because of these genetic defects
We need to add this so there's just different things that we need to support for a period of time depending upon the testing as well
So this is all part of your complete initial workup
This is what we do this whole workup and testing
Now that doesn't mean you don't retest and we'll set up times to talk about the results of those tests
So recheck your cheek swab because hey, we want you living you know 10, 15, 20 years way beyond
You're supposed to live with this cancer diagnosis and have a happy successful life
Or we need to keep you there so you never stop taking care of yourself
So we're always here for you. That's what we always say hey, will you come to us?
You're here forever with us. I don't ever plan on retiring
I'm always going to be here for you as long as God has me on this planet
So that's our complete initial workup and testing. I'm going to have some videos
Below that go over the specific tests to help you understand it because I realize
Look at at a microtox test. Okay, it's like drinking from a fire host. So I created videos to help you understand those tests
And really nerd out out of those things for those that want to all right. God bless. We'll see you down the road